[Music]
the u.s special envoy for haiti has
resigned over what he calls the inhumane
treatment of haitian migrants by the us
government
in a letter the ambassador daniel foote
says u.s policy to deport thousands of
haitian migrants and refugees are
counterproductive and deeply flawed
the biden administration is using a
trump-era policy to justify mass
deportations back to haiti but doing it
at a faster pace al jazeera footage
showing the mistreatment of migrants
along the u.s border caused outrage
earlier this week border agents on
horseback could be seen chasing people
back as they attempted to enter the u.s
let's go to kimberly holcott who's live
for us in washington d.c kimberly so the
biden administration say they are
dealing with this migrant situation but
this seems to suggest they clearly are
not
yeah it's it's been a problem for the
biden administration we watched the
white house press secretary jensachi for
days struggling to answer reporters
questions when sort of the obvious
hypocrisy is being pointed out with
regard to the biden administration's
immigration policy along the border
number one is that
haitians are being rounded up and sent
back to their country
while others are being welcomed in some
cases to the united states from central
america and of course we've just seen a
one of the biggest humanitarian airlifts
out of afghanistan so reporters are
asking what makes the haitians claims
any different the
parallels are eerily similar the fact
that they are also fleeing uh failed
state status type situations where there
is corruption there is economic uh
opportu there is no economic opportunity
there is gross poverty a lack of
resources
but the biden administration has
repeatedly said that they are simply
enforcing the policy they inherited and
the this is something that's being done
as a result of the covet pandemic and a
public health emergency the problem is
in all of this is that biden on day one
president biden undid many of donald
trump's policies but not this one so
it's hard to understand how this could
be an exception add to that
you have to remember that the biden
administration has repeatedly repeatedly
said that the foundation of its foreign
policy of all of its policies will be
compassion will be human rights uh there
has been repeated uh lectures if you
will even from this administration about
how it
believes that there needs to be more in
the united states with respect to racial
justice yet at the same time we're
seeing
inequality rampant along the southern
border so these are the questions that
the biden administration has struggled
to answer clearly internally there is
also an issue now because the special
envoy to haiti
has resigned he has submitted his
resignation uh saying that he can no
longer support the policies of the biden
administration he will not be associated
with what he calls an inhumane decision
to deport thousands of haitians who are
trying to immigrate to the united states
many thanks for that kimberly halcott
therefore is live in washington d.c